public sénat en partenariat avec la ffb
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pierre moscovici commissaire européen
aux affaires économiques qui est
l'invité de l'épreuve de vérité
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous s'ils
restent ce rendez-vous de public sénat
avec les échos avec radio classique qui
avec l afp est avec nous ce soir pierre
moscovici
lucile bréau et stéphanie le rouge
bonsoir mesdames trois grandes questions
pour vous au cours de cette émission un
déficit n'est-il pas temps de desserrer
l'étau on connaît votre référent votre
réponse évidemment mais c'est ce que
demande une majorité de français d'après
notre sondage exclusif
opinionway deuxième question quel rôle
vous voulez vous jouer dans la
renaissance de la gauche c'est d'arriver
un jour objectif 2019 les européennes
enfin troisième question comment faire
plier les géants du net dont les
milliards de profits échappe on le sait
à l'impôt ces parts et nous abordons la
première question
[Musique]
première question que vous pose lucile
bréau plus alors pierre moscovici la
france est plus que jamais j'ai envie de
le dire le mauvais élève de l'europe
on devrait passer sous la barre des 3% 2
9% déficit ça semble quand même
atteignable malgré tout et ce qui n'est
pas un peu temps de desserrer l'étau
aujourd'hui c'est la première question
est une question complémentaire est ce
que ce n'est qu'une étape descendent
sous cette barre des 3% genre tout en
composant la question vous avez donné la
réponse en réalité si on est comme vous
dites je vais pas utiliser ce mot là le
mauvais élève c'est pas le moment de
desserrer l'étau
je vais essayer de développer pour
sortir de la formule c'est vrai que en
il y avait dans l'union européenne 23
pays dans ce qu'on appelle à grossir de
déficit excessif d'ailleurs au-dessus de
3% mais nous sommes maintenant début
2018 y en a deux l'espagne et la france
et nous nous allons en sortir on est
tous les hôtels gîtes et et et la france
et l'espagne je l'espère en sortiront au
printemps 2010 87 pour pour ce qui
concerne l'espagne
je la situation est plus compliquée les
déficits espagnole en 2008 devrait
descendre beaucoup plus que le déficit
français
mais je ne sais pas exactement quel est
le résultat 2010 est pour ce qui
concerne la france
je peux pas dire j'en suis sûr mais j'ai
un espoir très solide
une conviction c'est que la france peut
le faire et va le faire qu'elle devrait
être en effet en dessous 3% 2010 est je
pense que la consolidation des résultats
et bien acquise et qu'elle devrait aussi
être en dessous de 3% 2018 mais dans les
deux cas devrait être de 7 de 8 nous
verrons quels sont les résultats de neuf
proches des 3 % alors que la moyenne des
déficits dans la zone euro et à 0 9%
je dis bien 09 et pourrait être un peu
inférieur si la croissance continue
conséquence de cela bonne nouvelle la
france va sortir de la procédure de
déficit excessif mais l'effort n'est pas
achevé il faut poursuivre ce qu'on
appelle la réduction des déficits
structurels
il faut rejoindre progressivement le
peloton de tête
il faut continuer à avoir une attitude
de modernisation de réforme de l'état et
de la dépense publique et pour le dire
en français plus compréhensible il n'y a
pas de cagnotte de cagnotte
et ce serait même une île
lyon de penser avant greffier mondial
des biens supérieurs on parle de 8
milliards d'euros grâce cette croissance
qui est plus forte que prévu une
cagnotte mais ce sont des plus values
fiscales en toute hypothèse
l'objectif il faut bien comprendre une
chose c'est que 3 % les fameux 3 % c'est
un débat français franco français et
seulement français que la plupart des
pays de l'union européenne résonne
maintenant sur les déficit dit
structurel qu'ils ont oublié depuis
longtemps
7 ce chiffre que 3%
ce n'est pas une cible c'est une limite
et qu'il faut continuer à remplir ses
objectifs quand on est en dessous et
continuer à faire des efforts pas pour
le plaisir mais juste pour faire en
sorte qu'on arrive enfin à désendetter
l'économie dette publique française est
très élevé les supérieur à 95%
voilà pourquoi je pense qu'il faut mener
une politique qui ne fait pas une
politique d'austérité je suis
radicalement hostile ou buddy
d'austérité qui appauvrissent l'état qui
appauvrissent les agents et sa commune
il est victime sérieuse une politique
sérieuse et une politique qui qui qui
transforme la dépense publique permet de
dégager des priorités pour l'avenir mais
qui en même temps limite la dette parce
que vous savez quand le service de la
dette c'est-à-dire le remboursement
annuel de la dette est élevée à ce
moment là c'est autant d'argent qu'on a
au moins pour l'éducation pour la
justice pour l'hôpital et mettons-nous
aussi en tête qu'il faut toujours penser
à demain avec les toqués risque donc que
nous vivons dans un univers qui est en
évolution et que progressivement
je pense en europe de manière modérée et
graduelle les taux d'intérêt vont
remonter et donc le service de la dette
risquent de remonter à nouveau
on ne peut pas on ne doit pas gonfler la
dette publique
il n'y a pas de cagnotte quand on est
juste en dessous de 3% il faut continuer
les efforts et non pas les relâcher et
voilà pourquoi il faut amener une
politique intelligente pas austère mais
sérieuse vous fait oeuvre de pédagogie
mais il y a une personnalité politique
en france qui n'est pas convaincu parmi
d'autres
c'est benoît hamon on va écouter ce
qu'ils nous disaient ici même la semaine
dernière de cette politique ou
contraintes budgétaires avec ce genre de
scénarios de politique on peut mourir
guéri passionnante mourir guéri mais on
meurt quand même à la fin
quittons je sais veux-t-on avoir un
grand hôpital public veut ton avoir une
politique de prise en charge du grand
âge à la hauteur de l'idée qu'on se fait
de la dignité des femmes et des hommes
c'est ça qui doit nous conduire c'est ça
qui fait qu'on fait de la politique on
fait pas de la politique en disant tiens
je vais faire 0% de déficit
le bug c'est quoi ré c'est qu'on a le
chômage de masse le bug c'est qu'on n'a
pas la croissance
le bug c'est que l'hôpital public c'est
de la merde parce qu'on n'a pas de marge
de manoeuvre budgétaire mais vous
rentrez dans les débats politiques n'ont
pas de la même manière non ce qui me
préoccupe moi mais c'est non mais c'est
pas de l'économie on vous en fait si
vous faites de l'économie vous en fais
pas de la bonne puisque à la fin qu'on
fait pas de croissance on a toujours du
chômage et des inégalités qui se
creusent
alors réduire les déficits et il sait
mourir guéri ce que vous dites ça vous
avez les rats car je suis un peu
accablée va dire parce que désolé
d'abord d'abord il y à une contre vérité
absolue dans ce qu'il dit mais absolue
c'est que c'est que la croissance est là
la croissance et à 2 5% en europe en
2010 est plus élevé que les états unis
elle est à 1 8 % en france et devrait à
2% 2018 est encore 1,8 en 2020 mais la
vérité c'est qu'on crée des centaines de
milliers d'emplois dans l'hexagone
aujourd'hui même s'il faut en créer
beaucoup pour faire réduire le chômage
la vérité c'est que le chômage baisse
même s'ils ne baisse pas assez et pour
ça il faut avoir une politique qui soit
une politique de flexisécurité et sartre
c'est la vérité pardonnez moi puisqu'il
parle de l'hôpital c'est que plus on est
endetté
on a d'argent pour l'hôpital et donc en
maintenant la politique de gribouille à
la barre ou factices hamon alors là on
est sûr de son coup
à l'arrivée on meurt pas guéri on meurt
balade c'est à dire que la dette explose
on n'a plus d'argent pour faire quoi que
ce soit en matière de services publics
et en plus on est soumis à la loi des
marchés le plan b à la da rocha qui
seraient vus en grèce s'est passé deux
jours en grèce en france on peut
vendre son livre faire des commentaires
faire des listes avec lui la vérité
c'est que les six mois que varoufakis
sont passées au ministère des finances
de la grèce ont ruiné le pays que quand
il a été là à promouvoir son plan b
pendant ce temps la croissance a été
nulle et que à la fin ils ont fait des
dizaines de milliers de chômeurs en plus
en grèce on lui dit pas merci
et bien en france je souhaite pas qu'on
mène cette politique là c'est une
politique d' irresponsabilité et
d'inefficacité cette année mais je t'en
prie sortir de deux
la procédure de déficit excessif et
uniquement grâce à la croissance c'est
suffisant c'est satisfaisant emmanuel
macron là vous vous trouvez qu'il en
fait assez justement pour que pour que
ça perdure il va assez loin ou lui dit
quoi fonte continue ses 29 ans quelles
que soient les ressorts par lesquels on
en sort c'est suffisant et c'est tant
mieux moi dans ma fonction de
commissaire chargé des affaires
économiques et financières je suis
responsable de la surveillance
budgétaire est ce qui la france deux
années de suite fait moins de 3% et si
en plus les perspectives c'est qu'elle
continue au moins trois enfants elle
sortira de la pression d'un déficit et
ce sera une bonne nouvelle mais quand on
est sorti la pression des effets
successifs ça ne s'arrête pas il faut
continuer à pédaler il faut réduire les
déficits structurels il faut maîtriser
la dépense publique il faut faire de la
dépense publique intelligente
en effet il faut privilégier l'hôpital
au service de la dette
la meilleure façon d'avoir des hôpitaux
qui marche c'est d'avoir moins de dettes
c'est faire exactement le contraire que
ce que préconise benoît hamon qu'est ce
qui effectivement faudrait quand même
bien de travailler un tout petit peu
l'économie car faire uniquement de la
politique ça mène à une
professionnalisation incompétente
la cour des comptes a raison en jugeant
que l'effort du gouvernement est
largement insuffisant au niveau des
économies
vous partagez cet avis que didier migaud
vince stats et eddy j'étais là d'un
gouvernement trop laxiste elle puisque
j'étais oui à présent je suis membre
la cour des comptes aussi après une
vision d'un gouvernement trop laxistes
ils jugent durée pas les choses comme ça
ce que je constate en effet c'est que le
passage sous 3% et edu davantage à la
reprise la croissance qu'à la maîtrise
de dépenses publiques et je souhaiterais
qu'on puisse marcher sur les pieds ce
n'est plus de croissance plus de
maîtrise des dépenses publiques la
maîtrise des dépenses publiques
encore une fois n'étant pas antagoniques
des services publics si ça se traduit
par une vraie transformation d'état vous
savez qu'il ya une commission qui a été
installée salle et à 2022 sous la
présidence de frédéric non le directeur
de sciences-po moi j'attends beaucoup de
cette réforme là je pense que le premier
budget de
emmanuel macron edouard philippe des
forcément un budget qui était un peu
sous pression des événements mais je
souhaite que les suivants marque
clairement un processus de réforme de
l'état et de réforme de la dépense
publique et je pense d'ailleurs que
c'est l'intention du gouvernement je le
ferai pas à cet égard de mauvais procès
d'intention mais il faut en effet que la
france devienne une championne pas
uniquement qu'elle soit là un reprenne
sa place dans le peloton moi j'ai une
haute idée de ce pays qui est mon pays
que j'aime je souhaite que la france
soit un exemple et quand on a comme
emmanuel macron une haute ambition pour
l'europe alors on doit avoir à vous
soucier beaucoup d'exemples
d'exemplarité
stéphanie la france est la france je
n'aime pas tellement frenchies bac
non pas parce que c'est de l'anglais
mais parce que je pense que la france a
toujours été là la france va mieux je
préfère le dire comme ça et la france
parlent plus fort et c'est très bien de
famille oui pour réduire les déficits
certains de vos camarades socialistes
évoquent la possibilité de ne pas faire
les cadeaux fiscaux qui ont pu être
faits aux plus aisés dans ce pays
notamment la modification qui a été fait
sur sur l' isf
est ce que vous partagez ce point de vue
est ce que là il y avait une économie de
dépenses à faire pour c'était des choix
qui était possible d'ailleurs on avait
vos sentiments votre avis mon sentiment
mon avis je suis pas beaucoup dans la
politique au jour le jour en france
voilà c'est mal écrire un livre qui
s'appelle danse est clair obscur
surgissent les mots s'en va en parler
dans ce livre je dis de manière assez
clair que l' isf à mon sens c'était un
des rares impôt anti rente et que si on
veut supprimer la rente c'était pas
forcément la priorité des priorités mais
ce n'est qu'une opinion d'accord mais
vous allez devenir aussi que maintenant
c'est le président des riches puisque je
ne jouais pas une formule que
j'utiliserai je pense me le présenter
comme un ploutocrate n'est pas exact je
pense que c'est quelqu'un qui a
l'intention d'émanciper mais je ne crois
pas non plus forcément la théorie de la
cordée parce que quand j'observe
empiriquement les choses je pense que
les premiers de cordée non pas une
générosité spontanée avec ceux qui sont
debout de ladite cordes et c'est ce que
vous écrivez effectivement un moment
dans mes livres sûr mais je reste un
homme de gauche je suis un homme de
gauche et je suis né comme ça je mourrai
comme ça simplement par rapport à ce que
disent les socialistes est quand même un
petit problème c'est que ça a été voté
et donc maintenant il faut que les
budgets de prochain soit des budgets qui
met l'accent encore une fois sur la
dépense publique vous attendait beaucoup
de la réforme de l'état qui est annoncée
vous êtes vous courent les départs
volontaires les plans de départs
volontaires de fonctionnaires pour la
fin éventuellement du statut
les fonctionnaires en très forte et
encore une fois pas entrer dans ces
détails là si j'étais encore de calmants
globalement je ne suis pas du tout dans
cette logique
moi je suis commissaire européen et je
pense que cette à l'union européenne de
fixer une communauté d'objectifs mais le
choix des moyens appartient
souverainement aux états membres et
celui ci a par exemple aux français je
vous avais annoncé notre sondage
opinionway souhaitez vous que le
gouvernement poursuivre sa politique de
réduction des déficits
et bien c'est un oui à 44% mène une
politique de relance quitte à abandonner
l'objectif de réduction des déficits
mais cela est majoritaire à 53% vous
n'êtes pas surpris vous vous dites qu'il
va falloir encore faire de la pédagogie
il faut faire beaucoup beaucoup au delà
de benoît hamon
ce kit qu'il faut tu me suis pas sûr
d'arriver à convaincre mais ce qu'il
faut surtout arriver à faire comprendre
c'est que l'excès de déficit n'est pas
un atout j'ai aussi des deux pays dans
l'union européenne y en a un qui est des
déficits élevés avec un taux de chômage
qui a été de 20% qui est encore proche
de 15%
un autre qui a un excédent budgétaire et
qui est au delà du plein emploi
il y en a un qui s'appelle l'espagne en
out qui s'appelle l'allemagne lequel est
ce que c'est le pays qui a fait beaucoup
de déficit qui est en plein emploi est
en excédent non et je dis pas que nous
devons faire l'allemagne petits pas
qu'une voile sur ce modèle mais je dis
que la politique d'argent facile la
politique de déficit excessif c'est une
politique qui appauvrit l'état et qui en
réalité ce retour d'accord contre
l'emploi et ça il faudrait l'expliquer
j'aimerais entendre plus souvent en tout
cas moi je le dis où l'été voilà alors
les dernières questions
je pense que réduire les déficits et 3%
en dessous 3%
c'est une politique de gauche seront
bien vous dit combien faut il de voir
combien il faut être des mérigots il
faut respecter les règles et normes sont
bien en dessous de 3 oui programmes sont
progressivement en dessous de 3% avec un
rythme qui sont à rythme soutenu mais en
dessous de 1 entourent bien parce que je
vous dis ça parce que je pense que
combattre la dette la dette est
l'ennemie de la gauche quand on
s'endette on s'appauvrit
quand on s'appauvrit on ne peut pas
développer les services publics canton
réduit la dette on retrouve de la
souveraineté on retrouve des moyens pour
les services publics c'est ça qui va
permettre de développer les services
jean pierre moscovici sur laurent
wauquiez désormais c'est le patron de la
droite
est ce que la politique qu'il défend est
ce que sa manière de considérer l'avenir
également en europe dans la perspective
qui s'ouvre on comprend quand même un
peu plus de protectionnisme
est-ce que comment comment vous la jugez
comment voulu juger parle beaucoup des
attentes sociales pour moi je vous
laisse aller ses politiques ni sur le
fond ni dans la forme mais je vais me
retenir de jugement de leurs excessif je
me contentais d'un sujet qu'est l'europe
et je trouve qu'il est en train de faire
prendre la droite française
un virage euros réticents eurosceptiques
euros négatif qui est extrêmement
mauvais pour le pays je pense que cette
petite la thune politique des classes
qu'à la france et qui amoindrirait à
l'europe et que dans la situation où
nous sommes dans le monde nous avons
besoin d'une europe plus forte et plus
intégrée pas du moins d'europe ou du
protectionnisme du souverainisme rampant
de monsieur wauquiez monsieur wauquiez
fait fausse route et et là on voit bien
quand même qu'il ya une ligne de
fracture à droite et que des hommes qui
ont toute leur vie et des femmes
souhaité davantage de rente ne peuvent
pas continuer à vivre dans un parti qui
désormais n'a plus l'europe au coeur
quand je pense à alain juppé quand je
pense à jean pierre raffarin quand je
pense à valérie pécresse a d'autres à
l'évidence cette vision rabougrie
riquiqui souverainiste négative est une
vision qui ne peuvent pas partager donc
il ya des facto une sorte de scission en
tout cas intellectuelle chez les
républicains qui est déjà fait et c'est
la responsabilité de leur nouveau
président qui a choisi cette stratégie
tout à fait à dessein parce qu'on voit
bien ce qu'il faut faire c'est garder
une base sociologique et ramener à lui
les électeurs du front national
ce sera une impasse à la fin deuxième
partie des preuves de vérité tout de
suite avec stéphanie le rouge qui va
vous vous posez la question vous
concernant vous et votre avenir votre
future politique
[Musique]
stéphanie oui donc c'est une question
qu'on souhaiterait vous poser c'est
celui du rôle que vous souhaitez jouer
dans la renaissance de la gauche et
particulièrement du ps
est ce que vous avez des ambitions
notamment par rapport aux élections
européennes 2010 j'ai une très grande
ambition et je peux l'annoncer ici c'est
de réussir ce que je fais comme
commissaire européen
c'est de faire en sorte que la grèce qui
a failli sortir la zone euro il reste et
sort de son programme à l'été j'ai une
très grande ambition c'est de faire en
sorte que la lutte contre la fraude et
l'évasion fiscale on parlera tout à
l'heure des gaffes à progresser encore
et j'ai une très grande ambition pour la
gauche c'est que c'est de continuer à
faire des politiques économiques qui
soient sérieuses mais qui ne soit pas
austère de faire en sorte que cette
politique soutiennent la croissance en
europe et ça ce sont trois objectif que
je poursuivrai jusqu'au bout de
montbrillant pour l'abroger et je suis
candidat à ça je trouve que c'est déjà
pas mal je le pense si vous voulez j'ai
une petite expérience de la politique
que quand on est dans un travail qui est
très important qui est important pour
les gens au fond et qu'on commence déjà
à penser à ce qu'on fait après il a volé
des réalisations kong et non des jeux je
ne suis pas au moment de penser à
l'avenir
je ne suis pas dans la préparation de
candidature j'entendais des commentaires
là dessus non je suis aujourd'hui
à ce stade je ne présente pas de
candidature politique mais ce qui est
exact c'est que je suis toujours un
homme de gauche
c'est que je veux réfléchir à l'avenir
de l'europe et de la gauche que je veux
le faire avec mes amis européens peut
donner
j'aime autant parler j'avoue de l'avenir
de la gauche
comme je lé fais athènes m'exalte city
press ou à lisbonne avec antonio costa
que d'en parler
tiens je ne sais pas avec le cameroun
assou avec stéphane le foll je pense que
il faut aussi être capable d'élever sa
vous parler plus facilement
on n'est pas citée c'est parce que c'est
de lui dont vous êtes le plus proche
mais je suis pas un acteur de ce combat
du parti socialiste une journée faite
temps et aujourd'hui je suis avant tout
un commissaire européen est un homme de
gauche c'est pas évident à la tête du
pays pas du tout sont pas au niveau de
ce que vous n'essayez pas du tout ce que
je vous dis c'est ce qu'on comprend je
vous dis que si dans mon travail
quotidien qui est d'oeuvrer pour le bien
des européens et français et de faire en
sorte que la france l'europe et la
gauche trouve rapprocher je m'investis
fait dans un congrès du ps alors une
certaine façon je
créditerait ce que je fais je veux
rester parfaitement crédible est
parfaitement libre et en même temps
comme dirait l'autre
je suis un homme de gauche je reste un
homme de gauche j'entends participer au
débat d'idées
j'écris je m'exprime et je le fais avec
au fond ce que j'ai toujours été c'est à
dire un homme qui se situe au carrefour
que de l'engagement pour la france de la
conviction européenne et de la passion
de la gauche et de la jeunesse macro
nist si on vous écoute vous êtes très
proche sur le rôle incarné vous croyez
qu'il dirait tout ça je pense je veux
pas qu'elle disait qu'il était devant
moi je suis pas ni de droite ni de
gauche ni de droite et de gauche je suis
très clairement de gauche et je me suis
relevé
ce sont des valeurs que mes parents
m'ont légué avec laquelle j'ai toujours
vécu sur lequel je resterai parce que je
me sens bien c'est à dire que moi je
pense que la lutte contre les inégalités
la révolte contre l'injustice est un
moteur pour moi c'est un moteur intime
et ça le reste toujours j'ai fait
beaucoup de choses qui paraissent plus
sérieuse mais j'ai gardé peut-être moi
c'est pas cette âme d'enfant mais cette
passion de l'égalité dans votre livre
vous souliers néanmoins la très grande
proximité de vos idées enfin des idées
des sociaux démocrates avec celle d'
emmanuel macron notamment sur l'europe
du coup on se demande forcément quel
pourrait être le programme l'espace
politique d'une liste socialiste et vous
pourriez je veux dire j'ai dit deux
choses là-dessus la première c'est que
je me réjouis que la france est un
président pro européen on attendait un
président pro européen qui s'exprime
avec force sur l'europe et je me sens
oui très proche des manuels macron sur
ce terrain là c'est le président n'a
qu'une française je veux l'aider à
relancer l'europe et je dis à mes amis
sociaux démocrates que plutôt que de
chercher une différenciation là dessus
il ferait mieux de s'approprier ce
discours là parce qu'au fond c'est le
discours qu'ils auraient pu tenir et qui
devrait tenir depuis longtemps c'est
celui que je tiens depuis longtemps
proposé un budget de la zone euro ou un
parlement la zone euro ou amis des
finances de la zone euro l'avait fait
dès 2013 vous comprendrez que je ne vais
pas me distinguer de ce que je pense
depuis toujours pour le plaisir de me
poser mais que peut faire la gauche
sociale-démocrate la gauche sociale
démocrate
lorsque il faut qu'elle ait une
conviction européenne ancrée qu'elle
soit ultra européenne et donc elle ne
laisse pas l'europe comme la propriété
de la droite et du centre
et il faut qu'elles soient aussi
vraiment de gauche et qu'elle ne laisse
pas la gauche nationaliste jean luc
mélenchon aujourd'hui c'est un homme de
gauche nationaliste
benoît hamon son programme est un
programme d'illusions pro européenne et
de réalité de déclin et donc il faut que
les sociaux-démocrates se positionne là
c'est à dire à la fois comme des
européens des réformistes une force de
gouvernement mais une force de gauche
est vraiment de gauche c'est leur espace
c'est leur canot et si ils font
autrement
alors ces élections seront une bérézina
on peut pas dans une élection européenne
quand tous les démocrates en vous on
peut pas le faire une bérézina signalé
quoi sinon vous allez va prendre les
jambes s'il y avait ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'une force sociale démocrate qui
irait un combat de cette nature-là en
dix ans nous soyons ni pro ni anti
européen elle serait inaudible il faut y
aller en mettant avec la bannière
européenne et la bannière de gauche et
les deux ensembles et là je pense qu'on
est fait il ya une place pour aller avec
ses arguments là peut-être que vous nous
dites d'une manière subliminale c'est
avec moi qu'il faut y aller je défendrai
ses idées en tout cas la rage et aux jo
je vais vous dire une chose de manière
pas du tout subliminal à c'est que
aujourd'hui je ne suis candidat à rien
que le temps des candidatures n'est pas
venue que ce que je veux faire c'est
travailler ou bien de l'europe et au
bien de la gauche dans mes fonctions que
pour le reste je n'exclus rien et je ne
prépare rien on en reparlera dans leurs
revenus et le moment est loin d'évoluer
partir honnêtement aucune campagne de
cette nature un an et demi alors qu'on a
des tâches importantes à faire ce serait
trop tard
en tous les cas stéphane son tour le
palois stéphane le foll vous a vu déjà
sur la ligne de départ et voilà ce qu'il
dit en évoquant ce matin les évoque les
candidatures aux élections européennes
il faut que ça soit là aussi des choix
qui permettent d'incarner quelque chose
de nouveau
non parce que vite 6-1 mais j'ai vu
qu'il était candidat et qu'il avait
apporté hier son soutien aux efforts
et donc moi il y aura pas de
distribution de postes avant le congrès
moi ce que je vais aller ma légitimité
j'irai la chercher chez les militants je
vais vous faire une confidence un char
j'aime beaucoup stéphane le foll est
très longtemps compris ils n'étaient pas
candidats se trouve que je ne lui ai pas
parlé depuis trois ans et demi donc il
donc il a dit un peu comme un
ventriloque stérile me prête une
candidature dont je viens de vous
expliquer pourquoi
à ce stade elle n'existait pas nous
verrons plus tard elle me prêtent aussi
un accord d'appareils avec olivier faure
qui n'existent pas davantage et
peut-être au fond est ce une sorte dé
formation professionnelle sa part il a
tellement fait ça fabriquer des accords
d'appareil qui est incapable de penser
que quelqu'un comme moi n'y pense même
pas mais pas là dedans je ne suis pas là
dedans et si un jour je dois être
candidat aux européennes
je le serai parce que ça peut être utile
à mon pays et au fort social démocrate
je ne le ferai pas dans un accord
d'appareils
donc il faut arrêter de faire la
politique comme ça je pense que ça c'est
vraiment de la vieille politique
non je ne suis pas en train de
s'écrouler il prône le renouveau est ce
que vous estimez qu'il a plus de crédit
que vous en la matière on entendu il
parle de renouveau de la gingivite peut
tous se renouveler et encore faut-il le
vouloir et le pouvoir
quel regard vous portez sur ce congrès
qui se prépare dans votre famille
politique à gauche et est ce que vous
vous estimez qu'aujourd'hui les
personnes qui ont candidaté parle
suffisamment aux français aux gens c'est
un congrès difficile parce qu'il
survient après des fêtes historiques
c'est ce que j'essaie d'expliquer dans
mon livre comment elle s'est passé au
fond et il faut faire cet inventaire de
ce canton pas de 30 % à 6 % en cinq ans
c'est un cataclysme politique qui s'est
abattue sur les socialistes et donc le
combat est très compliqué parce que le
regard des français est un regard qu'il
est un garçon indulgence voire parfois
de commisération
mais c'est un congrès important il est
important pour le ps lui-même c'est stop
ou encore c'est ont rebondi et on survit
ou c'est le déclin définitif et il est
important aussi pour les français il
peut être n'est ce pas conscient mais il
est important pour la france et pour son
équilibre politique démocratique qui
existe dans ce pays une force sociale
démocrate conséquente responsables pro
européenne et donc leurs devoirs
collectifs et à tous les quatre et aux
militants et aux autres c'est de faire
un congrès digne d'être un congrès
d'idées ensuite y en aura un qui gagnera
après des combats politiques c'est
normal mais il faut vraiment veiller à
ce que la tenue du débat soit bonne à ce
qu'on ne justement nourrissent pas des
rumeurs ou des intentions c'est pas la
hauteur à ce qu'on ait un débat d'idées
et ensuite que tout le monde se
rassemble
avec une ligne politique claire et cette
ligne politique je le répète elle doit
être vraiment social-démocrate au sens
du réformiste et européens on a compris
on est candidat à rien aujourd'hui met
en route sont quand même à la
disposition de votre parti kaladze cite
dans mon livre évoque une phrase de
talleyrand qui disait je suis à la
disposition des événements voilà je suis
pas la disposition d'un parti je suis à
la disposition des événements quand
j'aurai fini ce mandat j'aurais pas
encore forcément l'âge de rentrer chez
moi mettre mon survêtement voyageurs
d'autres ambitions du jeu brink à
l'heure j'ai par exemple on a parlé je
peux faire des tas de choses et met par
exemple président de la commission
européenne
étaient présents la commission
européenne passe à mon avis dans la
configuration qui est la nôtre par une
candidature aux élections européennes
pourquoi parce que je crois beaucoup moi
au principe de ce qu'on appelle les
chapitres seule candidate c'est à dire
des têtes de liste des grands partis
politiques européens je pense que le
débat doit avoir lieu
en europe devant les européens quand je
me disais que j'en parlais avec alexis
tsipras a soulevé contenu costa s'était
pas une formule c'est il faut bien que
la famille social-démocrate être un
candidat qui se présente devant les
européens qu'ils nous disent plutôt aux
autres et j'ajoute une deuxième chose
parce que je ne vois pas de
contradiction je suis aussi pour des
listes transnationales fait parce qu aux
élections mais finir vos ambitions sur
votre ambition j'ai envie de dire c'est
comme un train peut en cacher un autre
là les normes et sion peut en cacher une
autre alors qu'on me sollicite
présidence de la commission mais je suis
savez ce que c'est j'ai malheureusement
maintenant un peu l'expérience un
certain âge de ça donne une forme de
philosophie
ce que je veux faire du temps qui me
reste c'est être utile et je veux que ce
temps soit le plus utile possible s'il
est utile dans la politique ce sera la
politique s'il est utile dans autre
chose ce sera autre chose et si je fais
de la politique je leur ferai à fond et
avec passion si je fais autre chose que
de la politique je tournerai la page
complètement et je vous assure qu'il ya
là de la sincérité je ne suis pas dans
je ne sais quelle arrière pensée je suis
dans la liberté et dans la cohérence
avec ce que j'aime et ce que j'aime
encore une fois c'est l'europe c'est le
bien des français et mes convictions sur
les combinés gauche on est là dessus on
avait beau trop tard pour changer les
noms évoqués les listes ramallah les
listes transnationales vous êtes
favorable le parlement européen
malheureusement n'est pas d'accord avec
vous est ce que ça veut dire que c'est
la mort de cette idée que sont les
recours qui rêve je crois pas je pense
que il faut bien voir ce qu'elle
parlement européen
c'est cet appartement que les majorités
le vote a été relativement serré et les
conservateurs et les nationalistes qui
sont plutôt la majorité ont écarté cette
perspective ils l'ont fait pour de
mauvaises raisons
mais il ya des vraies questions les
vraie question c'est comment est-ce
qu'on rapproche le citoyen de
l'élection elle-même et comment
représentent les petits pays mais il ne
faut pas abandonner l'idée là et comment
je pense qu'il faut continuer en
débattre que ce vote est consultatif au
niveau du conseil européen
si j'étais emmanuel macron s'il avait
elle conseillé je lui dirai continu
continu et pardon monsieur le président
à défendre cette idée parce qu'elles le
méritent mais elle n'est pas
contradictoire de l'autre idée des speed
seule candidate j'irai même elles vont
ensemble ça que la logique voudrait que
le candidat tête de liste européens
souhaitent aussi à la tête de nice
transnationales sinon il se présentera
dans un pays mais il faut pas opposer
les deux il faut les deux à la fois
c'est ce qui permettra de donner à ces
élections une visibilité ou une
incarnation une image un enjeu est de
ceux-là surgira en effet le président de
commission européenne qui sera à la tête
de la coalition qui passe qui aura pas
de majorité qui sortira de tout cela
alors dans ce clair obscur surgissent
les monstres c'est le titre c'est une
formule de gramsci absolument qu'ils
sont les monstres aujourd'hui dans la
politique française
la formule gramsci il faut la cité en
entier c'est le vieux monde est mort le
nouveau monde parte à apparaître dans ce
clair obscur surgissent les montres sipa
les mons pour moi c'est pas des
personnes
les monstres ce sont les démons de
l'époque le populisme c'est le populisme
c'est l'antisémitisme c'est le racisme
c'est le terrorisme et le fanatisme
c'est l'intolérance parce que il est
quand même en france nous avons de la
chance c'est à dire que le dégagisme a
pris une forme qui est celle d'un jeune
président pro européen moderne mais dans
d'autres pays il a pris d'autres formes
ici c'est donald trump là c'est le break
site dans un troisième pays ce sont les
frères kaczinsky dans un quatrième c'est
monsieur urban et l'évolution au total
quand tu regardes le monde
elle est plutôt préoccupante est ce que
je dis c'est que dans le clair obscur où
nous sommes c'est à dire dans cet entre
deux il faut arriver à redonner du sens
à la politique est un bon gouvernement
et un bon gouvernement c'est un
événement qui rassemble et de ce point
de vue là moi je suis très favorable au
gouvernement de coalition
parce que j'ai une petite question
dernière la troisième place est en
transition évidemment avec les monstres
mais jérôme cahuzac
il a il était en appel aujourd'hui son
procès en appel
il a été condamné en première instance à
trois ans de prison ferme
comment le qualifie jérôme cahuzac c'est
un monstre vous pensez qu'il doit aller
en prison
j'ai eu il a fait appel parce qu'il
avait peur qu'il a lié aux gens j'ai été
son ministre d'un siècle est tellement
ministre délégué j'ai beaucoup souffert
de cette affaire y compris
personnellement parce que j'ai été
traité injustement deux complices ou
suspectés d'indulgence à son endroit
parce que comme tous les français au
fond j'ai cru ces mensonges les yeux
dans les yeux et depuis je m'emploie
mais tous les jours à lutter contre la
fraude et l'évasion fiscale et à faire
l'inversé ce qu'il avait à la
transparence par exemple sur les comptes
en suisse
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'échangé
automatique d'informations mais je n'ai
aucun acharnement contre l'homme
d'accord et on ne fera rien dire de
cette nature je pense que cet homme a
été aussi double qu'il a été brisée et
maintenant il est devant ses juges
et moi je ne suis pas un juge et je suis
un être humain et il est un être humain
aussi
troisième partie de l'épreuve de vérité
avec stéphanie qui va vous poser la
troisième question de cette émission je
reste ici
[Musique]
c'est avoue stéphane et de poser cette
troisième question donc la question
c'est comment faire plier les géants du
net
on sait que vous avez un projet de
fiscalisation des géants du net
est ce que pouvait être coupable d'abord
pourquoi faut-il le faire je pense qu'il
faut peut-être ainsi arrêté va pas se
lever il échappe à l'impôt aujourd'hui
quand vous prenez les entreprises du net
les grosses entreprises du net en europe
qu'elles paient en moyenne 9 % d'impôt
sur les sociétés là où les autres
entreprises payent 23,6 à une aberration
et donc ça cesse et c'est un problème de
règles équitables du marché c'est un
problème de distorsion de concurrence
c'est aussi un problème d'iniquité et
tout ça qu'on lui aussi est ce que nous
trésor public perdent beaucoup d'argent
et je conçois que nos concitoyens qui
eux payent leurs impôts comme de noms de
contribuables qui ont beaucoup donné
pendant la crise pour réduire les
déficits se disent pourquoi est ce que
moi je paye mes impôts comme un crétin
pendant que ces multinationales parce
qu'elles ont des armes et de conseillers
fiscaux d'avocats et c'est parce
qu'elles ont surtout des états à leur
disposition qui leur auraient par scor
et parce que les législations sont
exagérément favorable ici ou là ne
payent pas d'impôts donc voilà pourquoi
il faut le faire c'est vital c'est
indispensable une question d'efficacité
et une question de revenu fiscal et
c'est une question d'éthique
fondamentale nous allons nous attaquer à
ça et je peux déjà vous donner rendez
vous fin mars où je présenterai que juge
commissaire à la fiscalité ou ne pas
commission européenne un problème un
projet de taxation pas seulement des
gaffes à les cafés à ces quatre
compagnies mais le tout toutes les
grandes compagnies du net celles qui
font plus de 750 millions de chiffre
d'affaires
et il ya trois dimensions dans cette
taxation et une dimension mondiale parce
que c'est pas un problème qu'on
rencontre seulement en europe
il faut arriver à identifier ce qu'est
la présence digitale parce que au fond
s'il échappe à l'impôt c'est parce qu'on
sait plus trop ce qu'ils sont
notre apport sur les choses à faire à
l'intérieur des êtres notre impôt sur
les sociétés il a été conçu il ya un
siècle pour des entreprises qui étaient
physiques qui était localisé quelque
part qui en général et national
alors qu'aujourd'hui sont des
entreprises multinationales on n'arrive
pas à identifier les flux de données on
sait pas forcément où est ce qu'on
appelle l'établissement permanent donc
il faut reconstituer à partir du nombre
de clics et partir des données
hipay un martyr des recettes
publicitaires ce qu'est la présence
digitale dit une institution qui
s'appelle l' ocde
on travaille là dessus c'est une
institution mondiale elle va remettre un
rapport en avril parc des jalles
présenté en mars
il faut vraiment s'appuyer là dessus et
l'union européenne joue le jeu mondial
après une deuxième dimension que la
dimension européenne
j'ai proposé déjà une grande réforme de
l'impôt sur les sociétés qu'on appelle
l'assiette commune consolidée de l'impôt
sur les sociétés qui consiste simplement
à avoir la même base taxable partout
consolidé au niveau européen ce qui
permet d'éviter les transferts en
profite ce tir si vous êtes une
entreprise multinationale va vous taxer
au centre et je pense que c'est avec cet
outil là en y intégrant la présence
digitale me compote taxer les géants du
net coeur enfin une troisième dimension
de plus court terme qui permet de
générer des revenus pour le trésor
public qui consiste à taxer d'une façon
ou d'une autre
l'activité ou un chiffre d'affaires ou
une partie du chiffre d'affaires et je
ferai aussi une proposition de la
proposition que fera la commission sera
à trois niveaux mondial européenne
structurelles et de court terme pour
générer des revenus et je compte
vraiment beaucoup sur les états membres
parce que c'est une ride et les autres
responsables comptent sur les états
membres voient donc également sur
vous-même c'était l'objet de la deuxième
question de notre sondage opinionway
est-ce que leur parviendra empêcher
l'optimisation fiscale des géants du net
il ya
nous on vraiment majoritaire à 75 % non
75% comme si l'europe était un peu
plombé je ne sais pas par 120 capacités
et son impossibilité d'obtenir dans
moscovici des résultats concrets c'est à
la fois injuste et compréhensible plasma
nos concitoyens savent que c'est
extrêmement compliqué et voit que ça va
très lentement et ça va très lentement
pour une raison simple qui est que pour
faire aboutir un projet en matière
fiscale à l'échelle européenne
il faut qu'ils y l'unanimité des 28
états membres il suffit qu'un seul
s'oppose à la volonté de tous pour qu'il
y ait un veto et que ça bloque
ça peut changer mais il faut que les
états membres y consentent eux mêmes et
moi je crois beaucoup à la pression
populaire et politique
je crois énormément que les scandales
nous est puissamment un scandale c'est
toujours terrible scandale fiscal l'occe
félix panama peuvent paraître au
tribunal aujourd'hui par exemple c'est
un ace
ça nous aide ça nous aide parce que ça
me maintient la pression et est ce que
font les médias ce que fait le
consortium international des
journalistes ce que font les ong
ça nous elle aussi et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui les états membres sont
sous pression
tél les usual suspects les pays qu'on
qui ont des traditions fortes
d'encourager l'optimisation fiscale ne
peuvent plus opposés aussi benoîtement
leur veto à des mesures fiscales y sont
obligés d'entrer dans des compromis et
donc pour pour aller à l'encontre de ce
sondage
je dirais que je suis raisonnablement de
la garde mais je mesure les obstacles
je mesure la difficulté va falloir la
proposition de commission soit
extrêmement bien visée parce que si on
fait une proposition
magnifique mais totalement irréaliste on
sait qu'elle est déjà planté un lui je
vais essayer de faire une proposition
qui soit à la fois ambitieuse et capable
de faire consensus a pu ensuite je
mettrai la pression lui s'il évoquait le
procès là aujourd'hui à paris un apple
qui ripostent en demandant
l'interdiction aux ong donc de
s'introduire dans ses magasins français
et c'est notamment le attaque inquiets
qui est visée on écoute les députés
yannick jadot et eric coquerel qui était
présent tout à l'heure à la mi journée
finale certaines multinationales dans
plein de domaines essaye de contrecarrer
cette mise en transparence est mise en
accusation publique par des jugements
les jugements qui sont scandaleux parce
qu'effectivement plutôt que de payer ses
impôts apple préfère utiliser les
tribunaux pour empêcher les citoyens de
les dénoncer
chaque fois que l'union européenne a
avancé c'est parce qu'il y a eu des
lanceurs d'alerté nous au parlement
européen on a réussi à avoir une
commission d' enquête permanente pour
faire toute la lumière sur ces pratiques
et à chaque fois le message est le même
les multinationales doivent payer
l'impôt dans le pays où elles ont une
activité à l'ariane exado pour les
écologistes y avait donc aussi donc je
sais c'est aussi mon slogan la france
est comme ça c'est tout ce que je sais
de faire et on a obtenu contrairement à
ce que les français croient beaucoup de
résultats déjà depuis trois ans on a
progressé au palais d'affaires cahuzac
la sphère cahuzac à l'époque n'était
impossible de savoir si quelqu'un avait
un compte en suisse
aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on appelle l'
échange automatique d'informations le
s'est instantanément
et ça c'est un accord que j'ai passé
avec la suisse au nom de la commission
européenne mais aussi avec monaco et le
liechtenstein
avec andorre et saint marin il n'ya plus
de secret bancaire en europe donc on
fait de gros progrès et et le mode horde
doivent bien tu n'as il faut que les
entreprises multinationales payent leurs
impôts là où elle crée de la valeur et
des profits et je crois beaucoup en
effet au rôle de lanceur d'alerté
il faut les protéger je crois énormément
dans les vertus de la transparence alors
après est-ce que la transparence de
prendre des formes agressives
c'est un autre sujet je crois beaucoup
au rôle des ong mais pour aller plus
loin que yannick jadot et peut-être que
l'autre député que je n'ai pas entendu
éric auclair croire la gauche et donc
normalement fondamentalement au rôle de
la loi et je crois à la législation
européenne je sais qu'on ne fera rien de
décisif si on n'est pas capable malgré
l'arrêt d'une unité de légiférer là
l'union européenne s'est dotée d'une
liste noire des paradis fiscaux
les ong dont on parlait tout à l'heure
la critique le fait que certains pays
européens ne sont ne font pas partie de
cette liste noire
alors qu'ils ne remplissent pas les
critères qui leur permettent d'en être
exemptés donc ici notamment mike de
l'irlande les pays bas le luxembourg
pourquoi ne pas mettre ces pays dans la
liste noire des paradis fiscaux ce qui
permettrait peut-être de faire avancer
les choses
et parce que la liste noire des ong est
une liste noire si j'allais dire
qualitative ils portent des jugements
qui sont des jugements de valeur à
partir d'un faisceau de critères alors
que ce qu'ont fait les ministres des
finances et pas de commission européenne
c'est de partir de critères objectifs
qui sont ceux de la communauté
internationale c'est ce qu'on appelle la
procédure babes les du point de vue des
règles internationales il n'y a pas de
paradis fiscal en europe vous avez serré
de trop on attendait et donc je vais
venir
il n'y a pas de paradis fiscal au sens
où tous les pays observe ce qu'on
appelle échange automatique
d'informations maintenant l'irlande le
luxembourg le font aussi
tous les pays respectent l'ensemble des
standards internationaux et tous ont des
taux d'imposition qui ne sont pas des
taux zéro et donc on ne peut pas les
qualifier de paradis fiscaux ou sens de
l' ocde ou au centre du g20 mais je
pense que là où les ong ont raison c'est
qu'il ya ce qu'on appelle des trous
noirs fiscaux le trou noir fiscal c'est
un pays vous en avez nommer quelques-uns
où la législation est exagérément
favorable qu'on appelle l'optimisation
fiscale ou la planification fiscale
agressive et donc il faut mener un
raisonnement différent qu'ils soient
récemment citoyens ou économique
c'est-à-dire aller rechercher où sont
les plus tôt que quand vous voyez en
effet qu'il ya un maximum d'opérations
d'entreprises multinationales
prenez le cas d'apple je vais pas parler
des magasins que j'ai parlé de ce qu'a
fait ma collègue margaret weis tagueurs
quand elle a dit qu il fallait qu apple
rembourse 13 milliards d'euros à
l'irlande pourquoi parce que le taux
d'imposition effectif je parle pas du
tout la position nominal théoriquement y
allant de 7,5 pour cent c'est déjà pas
beaucoup mais en réalité pour apple
c'est zéro et 0 5% et la ldd législation
anormal et donc il faut travailler sur
ces limitations
il faut les débusquer et puis ensuite il
faut les combattre et c'est ce que fait
marc basseng heures c'est ce que je fais
aussi par exemple quand j'écris à
hominis des finances de malte ou bien où
des finances de la grande bretagne sur
la fiscalité des yachts ou des jets
privés à malte ou dans l'île de man et
nous devons continuer ce combat là je
l'appellerai simplement pas combat
contre les paradis fiscaux parce qu'il
ne faut pas mélanger les pays de l'union
européenne leur problème est légèrement
différent de celui des pétitions sur la
liste noire elle est dernière question
en gala merkel peut-être elle était en
difficulté elle est à la tête d'une
coalition tout tout jeune est-ce que ça
reste un partenaire solide en gala
merkel dans le contexte on voit qu'il ya
une fronde des quadras de son camp qui
ont aussi envie d'y aller ça rappelle
certaines choses en france et ce qu'elle
peut tenir dans ce cas là est ce que ça
reste un partenaire solide
à la tête d'une commission qui est jeune
mais revoit qui déjà ancienne puisque
c'est s'ils ne poursuivent du
gouvernement précédent
et puis je souris quand on parle de la
faiblesse angela merkel on aimerait bien
être faibles comme elle parce que tout
de même elle avait plus de 30 % aux
élections 33 son pays est au delà du
plein emploi
la croissance allemande est a pas de 5%
les finances publiques allemandes sont
sur équilibré et ils font 260 milliards
d'euros d'excédent commercial là où nous
faisons 60 me régalais suffisamment
remise en selle pour relancer le moteur
franco-allemand je pense que c'est bien
et kasey kahne je pense que c'est un
leader solide et elle sera pour la
france un bon partenaire d'autant
qu'elle est allié à un parti le parti
social démocrate qui est le parti le
plus pro européen du champ politique en
allemagne et que on va avoir pour la
première fois depuis plusieurs années un
ministre des finances qui ne sera pas un
conservateur par l'austérité au goûter
sur l'austérité mais un social démocrate
qui restera quand même très épris de
stabilité faut pas s'imaginer que ça va
être tout à coup là c'est benoît hamon
et ben arfa qu'ils vont être déçus par
olaf scholz mais les autres européens
verront quand même un vrai changement et
donc je pense que d'ici au mois de juin
on peut lui espérer des percées en
matière de gouvernance
et d'instruments politiques dans la zone
euro mc on est par exemple quelle mine
et non mais j'ai toujours ajouter une
chose si on est toujours en train de
parler de leadership leadership
leadership oui je commence à avoir 25
ans d'expérience en affaires européennes
ce serait important les leaders mais la
base de tout c'est que paris berlin et
bruxelles avance ensemble
s'il y en a qu'un qui marche ça va pas
et je pense que là on peut avoir les
trois à la fois ce qui me rend optimiste
avec mesure avec volonté vainqueur merci
pierre moscovici merci à vous mesdames
la semaine prochaine c'est agnès buzyn
la ministre de la santé qui sera notre
invité bonsoir a très vite
[Musique]